[Music]
cross stitch for rappers are you joking
i'm an anomaly in this scene for sure
i'm emma mckee and i'm a cross stitch
artist
i create custom one-of-a-kind
cross-stitch jackets for chicago's
creative class
[Music]
cross stitch is a antiquated form of
stitching traditionally done by your
grandma
i fell backwards into it um i made a
present for my mom a couple years ago so
i taught myself how to cross stitch it
came very naturally to me and so i
decided to do more
i felt compelled to do it but i didn't
know what to do it for and then the
obvious connection was well i'll do it
for the things that inspire me and the
things that i loved were art and poetry
and music
[Music]
chancellor ever is like the the prince
of chicago you know he's chicago royalty
chance is one of my favorite rappers and
so i
made this jacket it was a three jacket
it was chances three i was like okay
i'll put this on twitter we'll see what
this does like 30 seconds later
chancellor has followed you chancellor
ever sent you a dm i mean he's like yo
how do i get this and i was like any way
you want chance
and he wore on the cover of billboard
and that was kind of like how it started
[Music]
this
is for
an artist named jenkins it's a heart
i've made something like 135 pieces in
the last four years
some of the people i've made stuff for
scizza major laser chance the rapper vic
mensah most deaf joey perp kendrick
lamar oh yeah lil yachty of course how
could i forget about lil yachty but the
majority of them are worn by people who
are not famous a lot of people i make
stuff for in chicago wear their stuff
every day live in the things cross
stitch is just a cross stitched it's
just a square you basically take an
image and you pixelate the hell out of
it so you map out a bunch of tiny
squares it takes a very good spatial
recognition a lot of patience and you
cannot mess it up my inspiration usually
will come complete finished everything
from a person it arrives in my head
fully formed and that's it i have no
idea how we get there i don't sit around
and think about it for somebody like the
way that i'm able to make something for
somebody is if it is there
i have to go out to the suburbs to buy
my thread it's all specialty i spend an
ungodly amount of money on thread it
would freak you out
i always say like the median amount of
time and a jacket is anywhere from like
50 to 60 hours
when you're done then you get to pull
the graph out and then you get to see
what it looks like when it's finished
[Music]
people call what's happening in chicago
or renaissance we have art and we have
music and we have all these people
making positive changes all these people
making incredible incredible stuff
i have a team that oscillates anywhere
from like 7 to 14 people
and they're all artists they're all
other chicago artists
we do these big photo shoots with people
it's like really the only way that i
catalog anything is by having pictures
of it i like those a lot the giving away
part is the best part to see something
that you've made affect somebody in what
seems to be a meaningful way is a pretty
emotional thing
the goal with the crosses jackets was
never to sell them or to make money off
of them
it's truly truly a passion project i'm
not gucci i'm just you know i'm stitch
god
[Music]
[Music]
with my work i want to create pieces
that engage community together
and allow us to
really celebrate something positive
and i love seeing how the action of
crocheting connects people together
[Music]
i'm olek i'm an artist
and crochet is my technique i was raised
in a communist poland with very limited
access to any culture and any public art
in 2000 i came to new york i was 22 i
had a backpack full of dreams and like
no money and i was asked to design a
costume for a dancer i couldn't afford
buying sewing machine so i came up with
the idea of using the crochet hook to
connect fabric together and after this
was like explosion i was crocheting
gigantic installation right away
crocheting is a process of making fabric
with one continuous loop
i travel around the world every time i
go all my projects somehow relates to
the community i'm working with
our pink house is the project i created
in avesta in sweden
this town accepted a lot of refugees
from syria and ukraine
in india we were crocheting a new skin
for homeless shelter
probably most people know my work
because of the wall street bull i
appreciate pink camouflage as the
respond to the recent market crash that
happened 2008.
[Music]
currently i'm working on a project i
love across the usa
i want to create a mural in every state
that portrays women that change american
history
i always create squares or rectangles
sometimes and then when i have enough
pieces i crochet piece by piece together
with the help of the local people who
want to be part of this action so first
i touch this i go through this
and then just go on a live and install
it
people want to be part of something
and i love seeing that hunger
that
people have to create something so
positive not just the image but the
power that every single loop is made by
somebody's hand
[Music]
complex
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
nosotros
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in saskatoon saskatchewan you'll find
four senior citizens making socks
lots and lots of socks socks by bob have
knitted 11
662
as of today
that's pairs of socks which means socks
by bob has knitted 23
324 individual socks 8.8 miles of socks
and they're all for charity
the man responsible for all these socks
is none other than bob rutherford
[Music]
enter bob's knitting machines
these super powered knitting machines go
at 90 turns per second that's pretty
fast
but what makes these machines special
are that they're self-made
i'm an experimenter i just build things
and it took a long time to figure out
how to do it but when you're retired and
nothing to do
it just sort of grew
by bob began in 2010 after the passing
of bob's wife edith i was a caregiver to
my wife before she died and my son came
home and said dad you need something to
do i said well i made these socks on
this first knitting machine
and that sparked an idea making socks
for those in need
but bob doesn't work alone he has plenty
of help
george cuts the tube link
glenn and barney they will knit two
socks by the roll
each week bob and his team made hundreds
of socks that they then deliver to
countless homeless shelters all
throughout canada the clocks are
delivered in alberta saskatchewan
dc red deer calgary some have gone to
the northern part of the province in
short they go to where they're needed
people gotta keep involved you just
can't give up because of breeding
or whatever the case may be i think that
knitting socks for
needy people is important people have to
reach out and touch each other i think
that they grow older and
this has helped me do that
and i think that's
the key to life
you don't give up and find a purpose
find something that needs to be done
and do it
[Music]
you